excusez muriel pénicaud leurs emplettes
rachète ce qui est au lycée olivier du
soft de travailler avec les partenaires
sociaux sur quatre sujets qui me
semblait devoir être approfondies afin
d'améliorer encore le projet de texte
soumis par le gouvernement au parlement
s'agissant de la réforme des retraites
ces quatre sujets c'était la pénibilité
la question des fins de carrière les
minima sociaux et la gestion des
transitions pour celles des générations
qui sont concernés par la mise en place
du système universel la réunion
multilatérale qui s'est tenue ce matin a
conclu ce premier cycle de concertation
sur un bon bilan
ce bon bilan n'est pas définitif mais il
acte de nouvelles avancées sociales pour
nos concitoyens et il nous laisse du
temps pour régler quelques points à ce
stade sans accord je voudrais remercier
les partenaires sociaux qui se sont
engagés dans ce travail de façon
constructive et ce alors même parfois
qu'ils ont dit et répété leur opposition
un régime universel de retraite voit un
régime universel de retraite par points
ils ont néanmoins choisi de participer à
ces réunions au plus grand nombre
d'entre elles est de faire part de leur
position pour évoquer avec nous les
avancées susceptibles d'être réalisés je
veux les en remercier faire dialoguer là
la démocratie sociale et la démocratie
politique c'est un exercice exigeant
c'est un exercice de responsabilité qui
honore ceux qui s'y livrent même s'il
les exposés à la critique
c'est un exercice de responsabilité qui
contraste peut-être avec une certaine
forme d'obstruction qui est mise en
oeuvre est assumée par certains font que
l'on critique le projet du gouvernement
et de la majorité c'est très sain et que
l'on s'y opposent dans la rue c'est
légal et c'est même normal mais je crois
que
privé la représentation nationale d'un
débat de fond sur un texte qui doit
engager le pays sur plusieurs dizaines
d'années c'est moins facilement
acceptable pour le gouvernement bien
entendu pour les députés de la majorité
il est de l'intérêt de notre démocratie
que l'assemblée nationale puisse être le
lieu d'un débat serein
passionné sans doute des réelles
un débat compliqué c'est vrai technique
c'est vrai mais qui aboutira je le dis
comme j'ai eu souvent l'occasion de le
dire depuis le début sur des avancées
sociales exceptionnelles
je voudrais vous présenter un bilan
rapide de la réunion de ce matin et donc
des concertations engagées sur les
sujets que j'ai évoquées concernant le
sujet des garanties en matière de
transition et je parle bien des
garanties en matière de transition
nous avons décidé d'aller plus loin que
le mécanisme de conversion des droits
qui avait été initialement proposé par
jean paul ii loi le haut-commissaire
proposer certains s'en souviennent
peut-être la conversion en point des
droits acquis au 1er janvier 2000 25
nous allons proposer après discussion
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales un système plus respectueux
de la réalité des carrières de ceux qui
entreront dans le système universel dans
la fonction publique les droits acquis
jusqu'en 2025 seront intégralement
comptabilisées et convertis en points
sur la base des six vrais derniers mois
de la carrière de même dans le secteur
privé la retraite sera calculée par
référence aux 25 meilleures années sur
l'ensemble de la carrière
je parle bien la transition vers système
futur et pas de ceux qui auront effectué
la totalité de leur carrière dans le
système futur c'est ce qu'on appelle
parfois le mécanisme de transition à
l'italienne et c'est de l'avis général
de ceux qui ont participé à la
discussion
le régime le mode de calcul
le plus respectueux de la réalité des
carrières réalisé par ceux qui vont
basculer vers le système universel pour
les fonctionnaires dont l'âge de départ
à la retraite sera à reculer du fait de
la réforme
nous avons retenu le mécanisme de
transition proposée par les
organisations syndicales
leur durée de service seront prises en
compte pour éviter les effets de seuil
brutaux conformément à nos engagements
nous car ans nous garantissons donc à
tous les assurés le maintien des droits
qu'ils ont acquis et une transition très
combative vous souvenez peut-être que à
l'occasion de la présentation ce projet
au conseil économique social et
environnemental
au début du mois de décembre j'avais
insisté sur la nécessité de veiller à ce
que les transitions soit le plus
respectueuse des carrières de chacun
quel que soit d'ailleurs le régime
actuel auquel il est affilié deuxième
sujet de concertation l'emploi des
seniors avec la conviction partagée
qu'il serait tout aussi absurde de se
priver de leur expérience que d'imposer
un couperet rigide qui nierait la
diversité des situations et la réalité
du marché du travail une transition
douce entre l'activité et la retraite à
temps partiel ou consacrée à la
transmission de leur expérience peut
contribuer au maintien dans l'emploi la
retraite progressive restera ouverte à
60 ans dans le système universel et elle
sera rendue beaucoup plus facile d'accès
nous étendrons ce dispositif à la
fonction publique au même âge soit 60
ans comme le demandent et des
organisations syndicales de la fonction
publique avec des paramètres adaptée aux
spécificités de ce secteur par ailleurs
la ministre du travail va initier une
réflexion autour d'un compte épargne
temps qu'ils suivraient chacun de nos
concitoyens tout au long de sa bile pour
favoriser une gestion de son temps de
travail de manière différenciée selon le
moment de la carrière
là aussi c'est un sujet qui est depuis
longtemps évoqué par un certain
vos organisations syndicales c'est une
belle idée et l'émission d' expertise
sur le sujet permettront de nourrir une
concertation sans attendre nous allons
déplafonné dans la fonction publique le
compte épargne temps pour rendre
possible des mutants en fin de carrière
par exemple à l'hôpital où chacun mesure
la difficulté est parfois il faut le
dire la dévotion et le dur métier des
aides soignants et des infirmières enfin
je le disais nous voulons mieux
valoriser l'expérience et seniors au
terme d'une carrière on a acquis des
connaissances à savoir faire qu'il
précieux pour l'entreprise et plus
globalement pour eux tous les types
d'activités pme tpe milieu associatif un
large consensus s'est dessiné pour le
développeur le développement du mécénat
de compétences notamment en faveur des
associations
dans le même ordre d'idées la ministre
du travail va mobiliser les branches
professionnelles pour mieux valoriser
les fonction de tuteur de maître
d'apprentissage vous savez l'attachement
qui est le nôtre au développement de
l'apprentissage
s'agissant de la pénibilité les attentes
sont fortes
actuellement les règles sont éclatés et
vous dire inéquitable les mêmes gestes
les mêmes risques
la même pénibilité parfois n'ouvre pas
les mêmes droits dans le privé et dans
le public et parfois en fonction du
statut de l'entreprise beaucoup plus que
de la différence entre les métiers on ne
se trouve pas soumis aux mêmes règles
nous avons décidé de tout remettre à
plat pour instaurer les règles et des
règles de pénibilité universel ce qui
implique de transformer comme l'a
souhaité le président de la république
logique de statuts en une prise en
compte équitable de la pénibilité
les concertations qui ont été conduites
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales ont mis à jour
trois priorités la prévention la
possibilité de reconversion et les
questions relatives à la réparation
alors premièrement la prévention c'est
important de commencer par là parce
qu'avant de réparer les corps
avant de prendre en compte les
existences abîmé il est utile de
commencer par un prévenu en restant
fidèle à la philosophie qui a présidé à
la réforme du droit du travail en 2017
et à laquelle plusieurs organisations
syndicales sont attachés le gouvernement
va inviter les branches professionnelles
à ouvrir des discussions dans les six
mois qui suivront la publication de la
loi pour lancer un plan massif de
prévention de la pénibilité
elles devront repérer leurs métiers
respectifs exposés aux facteurs de
pénibilité notamment les trois facteurs
dits ergonomique
c'est à dire ceux qui avaient été sortis
du champ de la pénibilité par les
ordonnances de 2010 cette posture port
de charges lourdes manutention et elles
devront proposer ensuite des actions
concrètes pour prévenir et réduire la
pénibilité dans ces emplois
la branche accidents du travail maladies
professionnelles doublera son engagement
financier en accordant 100 millions
d'euros pour cofinancer ses actions
auprès des entreprises pour la
prévention
deuxième priorité nous allons proposer
un amendement au projet de loi visant à
créer un véritable droit à la
reconversion pour les populations
exposées à toutes les formes de
pénibilité ce droit passera par le comte
de prévention de la pénibilité par la
mobilisation des branches la logique est
simple permettre un salarié exposé
depuis dix quinze ou vingt ans à une
forme de pénibilité de financer une
formation longue de six mois rémunéré
pour basculer vers un nouveau métier et
on comprend bien la logique si on a
passé une partie déterminante de sa
carrière
posez la pénibilité il est peut-être
plus intelligent de permettre à celui
qui le souhaitent de basculer vers un
nouveau métier qui ne sera plus exposée
la pénibilité
plutôt que d'attendre d'aller jusqu'à la
fin de sa carrière sans tenir compte au
moment de la réparation ou au moment
d'un départ anticipé à la retraite
enfin les concertations mis en avant la
nécessité de généraliser une visite
médicale systématique à 55 ans pour les
salariés exposés à des métiers pénibles
afin de repérer ceux qui pourront faire
valoir leurs droits en matière de départ
anticipé à raison d'une incapacité
permanente
là aussi il s'agit de faire en sorte que
le droit à fixer correspondent bien aux
droits réels à la capacité à faire
valoir un droit et pas simplement à se
satisfaire de ce qu'il existerait voici
les principales avancées que nous avons
formalisé ce matin il y en a beaucoup
d'autres et j'en ai l'occasion par écrit
d'y revenir je vous en dirai un mot
d'ici demain matin
le gouvernement et la majorité les
traduirons en amendement au projet de
loi pour autant sur certains sujets les
discussions vont continuer la question
de la réparation de la pénibilité
s'agissant des trois critères
ergonomiques par exemple ne fait pas
consensus entre les organisations
patronales et syndicales
j'ai bien noté la demande des
organisations syndicales d'aller plus
loin en matière de départ anticipé mais
aussi les craintes exprimées par
certains représentants des employeurs
face à des évolutions de ce type
le dialogue doit donc se poursuivre sur
ces sujets et les décisions devons être
envisagée en cohérence avec les travaux
de la conférence sur l'équilibré de
financement de notre système de retraite
j'ai également confirmé l'engagement du
gouvernement de revaloriser sensiblement
le minimum contributif de retraite
quiconque partir à la retraite à partir
de 2022 après avoir travaillé toute sa
vie
smic percevra au minimum 1000 euros en
2022 et 85% du smic soit environ 1100 47
euros à compter de 2025
certains partenaires sociaux veulent
améliorer ces paramètres
le gouvernement est disposé à en
discuter dans la mesure où toute
discussion sur ce sujet impliquera
nécessairement un coût pour la
collectivité qui lui reviendra d'assumer
ces discussions pourront avoir lieu dans
le cadre de la conférence de financement
tout en rappelant qu'il est légitime
dans notre société de conserver que le
droit à un écart entre un revenu
d'activité un revenu lié à la retraite
j'adresserai pardon cet après-midi en
fin d'après-midi un courrier aux
partenaires sociaux
comme je l'avais fait d'ailleurs le 11
janvier dernier pour leur confirmer ses
engagements et pour les préciser car là
encore beaucoup d engagement que nous
avons pris après discussions sont très
technique et il existe pour pouvoir être
expliqué et pour pouvoir être le cas
échéant a prouvé être rédigée de façon
précise les partenaires sociaux auront
ses propositions à la fin de la journée
à la fois celles qui peuvent faire
l'objet d'une traduction immédiate dans
le projet de loi par travers à travers
des amendements et celle qui imposeront
que se poursuivre le dialogue déjà
engagés il nous reste donc du travail
j'ai bien noté que certains voudraient
que cela aille plus vite pendant que
d'autres
photo pour que salah avec moins vite
avec les partenaires sociaux et avec la
majorité nous entendons garder notre
rythme celui du dialogue social et de la
démocratie parlementaire sans escamoter
les difficultés mais l'important c'est
d'avancer dans la logique je dirais du
compromis trouvé le 11 janvier dernier
et à laquelle le gouvernement tout
entier et moi même en temps de rester
fidèle je vous remercie et bien entendu
s'il ya des questions
je veux bien y répondre ainsi d'ailleurs
que leurs emplettes rachète ce qui est
du bief du sol
un internat remorque de du journal
actuel et le cso sur la question de la
réparation de la pénibilité
ce qu'il faut comprendre que vous
demandez aux partenaires sociaux lors de
la conférence de vie lancement ont
travaillé sur ce sujet de vous faire des
propositions pour un bricoleur suggéré
une nouvelle négociation parallèle je
crois qu'il faut que nous poursuivions
le fil de la discussion
je les dis je le dis clairement il n'y a
pas encore les conditions d'une
convergence et après tout quand on
discute et qu'on fait confiance au
dialogue social il faut aussi savoir il
faut se réjouir des avancées il faut
savoir pointe et les désaccords
permettez-moi d'observer qu'à
l'intérieur même de ce désaccord il y a
des points qui constituent des avancées
c'est vrai en matière de prévention ont
compris sur les facteurs et sur les
critères exclu c'est vrai s'agissant des
éléments de reconversion y compris sur
les critères de pénibilité exclu et
c'est vrai également en ce que des deux
côtés de la table si j'ose dire que ce
soit organisations syndicales et
patronales il y a des propositions pour
essayer de prendre en compte ces aspects
de pénibilité en termes de départ
anticipé
simplement ce ne sont pas les mêmes
logiques ce ne sont pas les mêmes
instruments et il y a des préventions
dans chaque camp sur les propositions
formulées par l'autre ça veut dire que
il faut encore avancée pour essayer de
trouver le maximum de convergence
possible et c'est ce que j'ai indiqué
aux organisations syndicales et
patronales ce matin
nous avons encore du temps pour discuter
et nous allons l'utiliser pleinement
voilà
et
les modalités de transition vous parliez
du fait que ça devait être plus
respectueux de la réalité des carrières
est ce qu'on a chiffré le coût que cela
pouvait engendrer c'est à dire de
changer de passer avec une clause à
l'italienne qui donc bah différerait et
frais coexister deux régimes pendant x
années chiens de toute façon quelles que
soient les quelles que soient les règles
utilisées pour la transition
nous n'avons jamais caché parce que
c'est l'évidence qu'il y à une longue
période de transition
simplement dans les règles de calcul de
conservation des droits acquis nous
avons choisi cette solution
il y avait d'ailleurs été travaillé très
tôt mais qui n'était pas la proposition
principale du rapport de le voir parce
que nous pensons qu'elle est plus
respectueuse des carrières
professionnelles sur les implications
financières
nous aurons l'occasion de répondre
certains qui aura beaucoup de questions
sur les questions financières
pour l'instant ce que je ce dont je veux
faire état c'est des points de
convergence des points d'avancé dans la
discussion avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales et j'observe et
je parle sous le contrôle de leurs
emplettes rachète qui olivier du soap
que tous ceux qui ont participé à ces
réunions pour converger sur cette
question de l'âme des modalités de
transition ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est
pas rien une dernière question peut-être
deux députés de la majorité qui vous ont
écrit pour lui demander des
éclaircissements sur l'impact budgétaire
de l'arrêt
d'abord que je me réjouissais beaucoup
que les éléments de responsabilité
financière de la réforme soit portée est
pris en compte par deux personnalités
éminentes de la majorité et je le dis
sans malice il est arrivé parfois dans
le passé qu'on ne fasse leurs proches d'
accorder trop d'attention à ces
questions d' équilibre financier de
vouloir trop souvent garantir le fait
que la réforme que nous portons soit
équilibré dans le court terme à
l'horizon 2027 voir dans le long terme
au fond je prends cette lettre comme le
fait que cette attente
attention permanente que je porte aux
questions d' équilibre financier de
responsabilité financière
attention permanente qui est
systématiquement rappelé par le
président de la république que cette
attention permanente est partagée par
les députés de la majorité et je m'en
réjouis pour le reste dans les échanges
nombreux quotidiens réguliers que nous
avons avec les députés de la majorité
est en vérité avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires nous serons amenés à
répondre point par point aux questions
qui ont été évoquées et leurs emplettes
rachète ce qui a déjà d'ailleurs donné
un certain nombre d'éléments de réponse
pendant la commission spéciale et
j'indique enfin que sur un certain
nombre de sujets qui sont évoqués par ce
courrier nous avons d'ores et déjà
répondu je le dis par exemple s'agissant
des éléments sur la rémunération des
enseignants
nous sommes engagés à procéder dans la
durée à une revalorisation massive des
rémunérations des professeurs et des
enseignants en général et nous avons
indiqué qu' il appartenait au ministre
de l'éducation nationale d'engager des
discussions avec les organisations
syndicales
ces discussions ont d'ailleurs commencé
vous le savez parfaitement pour
déterminer la façon dont nous allions
procéder à ces revalorisations le rythme
les instruments
la façon dont nous pouvions avec
construire une loi de programmation qui
sera préparée à l'horizon de juin
tout cela nous l'avons dit nous sommes
en train de le faire et c'est évidemment
un des éléments que j'apporte aux
questionnements que vous avez évoqué de
ces deux parlementaires
voilà ce jeu vous remercier et vous me
permettrez puisque vous n'avez pas posé
la question d'y répondre
néanmoins me félicitant vivement des
excellents résultats du chômage qui sont
tombés ce matin je sais que s'il avait
été moins bon voire neutre et peut-être
même mauvais il aurait été commentée
alors je me permets de me réjouir du
fait que nous avons atteint s'agissant
de la france métropolitaine et de la
france dans son ensemble le plus bas
niveau de chômage depuis près de 12 ans
cela montre qu' il y a encore beaucoup
de travail
la ministre du travail a elle-même
indiqué que dans 24 départements de
l'hexagone le taux de chômage était
désormais égal ou inférieur à 7%
nous avons beaucoup de travail devant
nous mais permettez-moi d'observer le
fait que la constance l'effort et les
mesures que nous avons prises produisent
des résultats et ça fait plaisir de le
dire merci beaucoup
[Musique]